avec sa dégaine d'anciens hippies martin
sorgues roule dans la campagne de la
rhénanie du nord westphalie il pourrait
passer pour un excentrique mais il a
accompli depuis de nombreuses années un
travail très minutieux aux résultats
très inquiétant cela fait 30 ans qu'ils
relèvent des pièges à insectes à 63
emplacement toujours identique dans
cette région allemande près de la
frontière des pays-bas extrême vestiges
d'assemblage par son mari il a constaté
que les données collectées depuis 1984
grâce à ces pièges qu'il a lui même
conçu sont d'une importance capitale
pour la recherche sur les insectes site
ont collecté les échantillons sont
ensuite analysés par son collègue
entomologiste ici tout le contenu de
chaque carton rempli de leurs
trouvailles dans un seul piège est
répertorié au fil des ans ils disent
avoir amassé entre 40 et 80 millions
d'insectes dans ses bouteilles remplies
d'éthanol le constat est effrayant
en trente ans la masse d'insectes
volants aurait reculé de 76% frères
martens org ne sais pas dans quelle
direction la situation va évoluer car
les conséquences sont difficiles à
prévoir des cadenas pour ce professeur
néerlandais ces entomologistes allemands
ont accompli un travail de visionnaire
et ils sont tout sauf des amateurs
ici au jardin botanique de montréal où
on effectue le même type de collecte
d'insectes on ne s'étonne pas du tout de
ces résultats inquiétants
il ya eu une méta analyse des
scientifiques qui ont pris 73 études à
travers le monde et à travers le temps
et qui ont justement corroborer les
conclusions qui avait eu les allemands
ce déclin est aussi perçue au canada par
exemple le bourdon à taches rousses qui
était très présent au québec a
complètement disparu un peu partout sur
la planète les causes de la disparition
d'insectes sont similaires
on a d'abord une intensification en fête
de l'agriculture
on a aussi l'étalement urbain et la
position et l'épandage de pesticides
dans nos systèmes d'agriculture
d'aujourd'hui les conséquences sont
évidemment terrible pour la biodiversité
et les écosystèmes terrestres
d'ailleurs la chute de la population
d'insectes en europe aurait contribué à
faire disparaître plus de 400 millions
d'oiseaux en moins de 30 ans lorsqu'on
voit des déclins en oiseau dans les
populations d'oiseaux des hirondelles
des amphibiens et des mammifères qui
dépendent justement des insectes comme
biomasse de nourriture et bien les
insectes sont à la base ce problème et
s'il décline tout le reste décliné pour
l'instant les entomologistes continue de
répertorier les insectes qui
disparaissent et même s'il ya de
nouvelles espèces exotiques qui font
leur apparition le déséquilibre avec les
insectes des indigènes et bien marqué on
en parfaite plus quand on découvre à
chaque année la pression sur la
biodiversité mondiale continue et les
scientifiques espèrent seulement que ce
ne soit pas irréversible ici frédéric
arnould radio canada montréal